I'm not sure which came first the
business interest in space or the hobby
I think they were coincident in a way
but well just so happens perhaps that
the timing has been remarkably good of
late to be looking at space as an
investment thing my name is Steve
Jurvetson I work at Draper Fisher
Jurvetson we are early-stage venture
capital firm and the best in startups
that are trying to change the world and
launch the SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket as
NASA turns to the private sector to
resupply the International Space Station
well I'm on the board of SpaceX and
we've invested in that company from
early on we have been investing in
rocket launch capacity putting things
into orbit and there's probably a few
more investments like that that you made
we're currently investing in low-earth
orbit satellites things that fly in
orbit moving around the earth it's a
model but it is a one to one scale model
meaning this is literally how small it
is that's the lens that's all it takes
you fly this close to the earth you get
as good a photo as those enormous
expensive satellites flying far far away
we like the low-earth orbit satellite
business because it's in a massive state
of disruption people are used to
building satellites that cost a half a
billion dollars than the size of a
Greyhound bus and they're now being
shrunk down literally something this big
I mean that big that cost tens of
thousands of dollars and you put
hundreds of them up and the entire
constellation costs a fraction of the
old model but provides a much better
service in that insight to have what are
almost disposable satellites would have
been unthinkable in the past when it
costs too much to get to orbit so as
your minimum cost of entry comes down
you do we think how you build the things
that go up there and that's what we're
in the middle of doing so we first
invested in SpaceX now we're thinking
about how do we re engineer how
satellites are made and then later it'll
be tourism and exploring you know the
frontiers of the unknown
we don't any wires on the other side
doing just the quick things no wires
wrap around me they okay I've almost
ought that it's actually healthy to have
a hobby to get out of the mental ruts
that academic disciplines and career
tracks imply four to five I think the
kids a hobby we could do together was
the initial inspiration working with
your hands almost like it's a form of
enrichment to have the things you do
everyday at work and then they have a
form of art or expression and then fire
school I should I mention that that
pyrotechnic urge I think runs deep
within my genetic material when they go
well there's a thrill of victory when
they go poorly there's agony to defeat
in the classic Olympics sense but it's a
visual spectacle
in both cases photography and rocketry I
like the fact that I feel like an artist
I'm meeting people where the
conversations are a different plane
that's up and it does infuse business I
mean literally I've invested in
companies I met in the Black Rock Desert
oh we're launching rockets there have
been more cross-pollination with work
than I ever would have imagined going
into this the photos I take I share a
lot of this online and it leads to all
kinds of conversations I end up learning
more I end up meeting people frankly who
are starting businesses in related areas
and if nothing else I create a different
network of science connections and
engineering connections that I would
just doing the same old thing every day
there's something about modern economy
of continual lifelong learning of moving
from one industry perhaps to another
which I love to do as a venture
capitalist that seems consistent with
trying to get out of your normal in a
sense intellectual pursuits so of all
these artifacts this one on this shelf
is particularly interesting in that this
has been on the moon for three days as
part of Apollo 17 what I love about the
things I collect is the stories attached
to them in almost no case do I think
I'll collect something because just this
thing and I'm trying to get all the
things in a series that just doesn't
motivate me it's the wow this item has
the following story or history test to
it and in the Apollo space program there
are stories everywhere all these amazing
stories come up on how they solve the
technical problems or you know a mishap
that almost would have been a historic
mishap that was solved in some way or
another or or the incredible advances in
science and technology that had to
happen with an incredibly short period
of time to pull this off
you know in every start if you have an
entrepreneur who has some dream or
vision the star that they see in the
horizon that carries you to a lot of
years of hard work and more prosaic
accomplishments in many cases but that
dream is really powerful in motivating
for the whole team and for investors in
companies like that I think we as humans
like to imagine what could be and
explore what hasn't been explored to go
to the deepest steps to go to the
highest heights and the folks who help
enable that and take this steps in that
direction are some of our greatest
heroes